[Music]
psychologists have discovered that your
response to a series of pictures can
actually help determine your personality
there's no wrong answer when looking at
these photos but they will tell you just
how artistic confident social and
nurturing you really are if you're new
to our channel don't forget to hit the
subscribe button and please give this
video a big thumbs up because today
we'll be walking you through a set of 10
pictures to test your personality part 2
10 depending on your age you'll probably
analyze this picture in a different way
do you see the lovers in the bottle or
dolphins according to research studies
children are unable to see the two
lovers because their brains are unable
to process and distinguish the risque
image so they see the image of dolphins
instead if you're unable to see the
Dolphins at all it means you're not so
innocent anymore and your mind may be
just a tad bit corrupted 9 there are two
images in this photo do you see the duck
or the rabbit if you saw the duck first
you're like most people in the world but
if you're able to switch back and forth
between seeing a rabbit and a duck it
means you're very creative and you have
the unique ability to see and analyze
the world in various ways 8 here's
another photo to test your personality
after taking a quick glance at this
image what's the first thing you see if
you saw the profile of an older woman
who looks sad it means you're a
pessimist and you're cautious about the
way you approach life if you see a young
girl standing and looking off into the
distance it means you're young at heart
and you have an optimistic perception of
the world 7 this artistic image can be
seen in multiple ways if you see an
explosion it means you're a very
creative and artistic person with a
vivid imagination if you see a tree it
means you're observant and if you see
two hands it means you always remain
calm even in the most stressful
situations
six and this photograph do you see a
face a person sitting down or apples if
you see a face it means you're very
curious and you're full of wisdom if you
see a person sitting down it means
you're well balanced and your life is
generally happy if you see apples it
means you're very social and it's easy
for you to get along well with others
five the Rorschach test is a series of
ink blots I can determine a person's
personality when you take a look at the
following ink blots what's the first
thing you see if you see a musical
instrument it means they're always in a
good mood if you see an hourglass it
means you have a well-developed ego if
you see a skeleton it means you have an
intense fear of getting sick and if you
see a duck or a crab it means you doubt
yourself and you don't think you have
two strength nor knowledge to solve many
of life's problems it's definitely time
for you to boost your confidence for
here's another ink blot
what do you see this time around if
you're like most people you probably see
a back that means you are a normal
healthy person if you see an elephant it
means you may be suffering from
insecurities and if you see a bird it
means you should stay single because
you're probably not emotionally ready to
be in a serious relationship three there
are seven different animals in this
photo which animal can you spot first if
you see the bird and the crab it means
you're very sensitive and you can be a
bit emotional if you saw the horse it
means you love being independent and
free if you saw the dolphin it means
you're a very creative person if you saw
the bear it means you're a natural-born
leader if you can see the dog it means
you're nice and nurturing if you saw the
ducklings
go ahead and give yourself a pat on the
back they are the most difficult animals
to see in this photo if you were able to
spot them in 30 seconds or less it means
you're very artistic too in this next
ink blot you see a roasted chicken a
cartoon cat who's in shock a faceless
woman wearing a wig a doctor working on
a patient's jaw or a rocket if you see
the roasted chicken it means you get
bored easily and you hate being alone if
you see a cartoon cat who's in
shop it means you're a very passionate
person if you see a faceless woman
wearing a wig it means you have very
high standards but you need to work on
your patience if you see a doctor
working on a patient's jaw it means
you're comfortable in your own skin if
you see a rocket it means you're a hard
worker and you're not afraid to
challenge yourself one this last photo
shows two sets of stairs which stairs
which you use to go up and which ones
would you use to go down the answer
depends on where you're originated from
if you read from left to right you
probably choose the stairs on the left
to go up and if you read from right to
left you probably choose the opposite
make sense right did you learn anything
new about your personality after taking
this test leave us a comment down below
and don't forget to give this video a
big thumbs up
you
[Music]